do you want to shuffle these Brady just
so people are happy that they're not in
a pre-arranged order I'm sure people
believe us but there we go I've shuffled
them up a bit no I can't do that either
so why I'm not attempting to do it on
camera right so we've got a randomly
shuffled plucker cards I don't know the
order they're in
um and I'm first of all I'm just going
to memorize them um so I'm just going to
deal them out and then try and remember
where they're red black and then we'll
go for it okay let's go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
black
black
red black
uh black
red red black
red
[Music]
red
black
red
black
red
black
[Music]
red black
red
black
red red
red red red
[Music]
um
red
um
red
[Music]
red
black
[Music]
um black
red black
red
black red red
black black black
final four red
black
red red
yay
you happy with it I'm very happy with
that well done very well done phew
genuine relief
I think quite a few people watching
might have spotted what I was doing
based on the gaps I was leaving so when
I was reciting them in particular I was
like I wasn't reciting them at a
consistent pace so I'd maybe I think I'd
do kind of six and then I'd often think
for a bit and then I'd do the next six
so I think that was a little bit of a
clue that I'm grouping these cards in to
six so groups of six and I'll just give
you an example so the first one and now
I've got to remember it was the first
one was uh first six was black and then
black and then black
um and then it was black again and then
it was red and then it was black so that
was my first group of six what I'm doing
is I'm taking the the second to the
sixth of that group of six
um and I am if it's a black card I'm
thinking about a one in my head and if
it's a red card I'm thinking about a
zero in my head and so actually what I'm
doing is I'm turning that set of five
into binary so this is uh this is a
binary number a string of ones and zeros
and then I'm turning that binary number
into base 10 in my head so in binary
this represents one lot of one zero lots
of two and one lot of four and then I've
got one lot of eight and then I've got
one lot of Sixteen so this is 29 so this
binary number represents 29 so I'm then
remembering 29. so essentially I've
condensed those five digits into this
two-digit number what about that first
number that's good question so this
first one is in my head
um sometimes I remember black as a
negative and red is a positive and
sometimes I just remember it as black or
red so essentially I found that I was
much quicker and much more fluent if I
just dealt with five digit binary
numbers as soon as I got to the sixth
um sixth digit I was getting I was like
was it 37 was it 27 I was getting really
confused and so I found it easier to
think about that bit of information just
as it is it's like black or red so for
each of these groups it's either black
or red and sometimes in my head I
imagine the number as black already so
literally this is black pen 29
um but then occasionally when I've been
practicing I've been remembering it as
minus 29 so it changes
um but this they say I'll just be just
to be clear this isn't signed binary
right so this is literally just this is
the binary number and then this is just
a separate bit of information
um so I had black 29 the next one I had
was black 25 uh and then the next one I
know you're asking me uh was red 10 I
think and then the next one was black
22.
um and then the next one was black zero
which was really nice that was quite a
gift and then the next one was red and
it was three I think and then the next
one was black again a lot of them are
black which is really helpful so only
had two Reds here and that was black 20
I think
um and then it was black seven each of
these are six and there's eight of them
so that's 48 cards only so the final
four I'm just remembering as what they
are there's only like not many patterns
you can have with four cards and it was
red black red red so I just in my head I
remember that as the second one is black
um so that's what I was remembering so
essentially eight one or two digit
numbers
a bunch of blacks and reds what's harder
the encoding or the decoding afterwards
ah the remember and actually neither so
I guess there's three processes the
first process is encoding so turning it
into the base 10 number second person is
just remembering it and then decoding
encoding and decoding I've just
practiced lots and lots I'm really quick
at it so that's not too hard it's still
remembering it's it's kind of trying to
encode in one part of your brain whilst
at the same time not forgetting all of
the numbers that have already come
through
um and the patterns so as I say this was
quite a nice one
um because I'm not going to do my trick
down but the fact that we've only got
two Reds and they had this kind of
symmetry so I see it like this in my
head so I see I've got eight things to
remember plus these little extra ones
black zero is that a black card and then
all reds yeah exactly so that was the
black cards and then five Reds so it's
just really nice like I probably smiled
when I doubt that out so if you if you
see on the
um that was yeah that was nice and then
also then in order to remember the
numbers
um often there's not too many patterns
in this well this one but often and if
there's a pattern that helps me remember
it so the other day I was practicing and
I had something like
14 and then seven that's half or another
one I did the other day I had 20 and
then three and then 17 and 20 take 3 and
17. so if I can spot little patterns
like that while I'm going along that
really helps me remember it
um it almost feels like it'd be easier
just to remember the 52 cards
um I yeah definitely not like I think I
think the key with this is that I'm
condensing the information so base 10 is
much more efficient than binary so this
is effectively binary right so black
Reds are the same as binary and so I'm
condensing like six or five digits down
to one or two digits
if you have a brain for numbers and
you're about to start University well
this could be your moment our episode
sponsor Jane Street is running its
Academy of math and programming it's a
five-week summer program for recent high
school graduates particularly those
who've experienced barriers to access
and opportunity it's happening in July
and all the expenses are paid including
accommodation travel and they're
throwing in a five thousand dollar
scholarship to support future
opportunities
if you're interested or maybe you know
someone who might be check out the
details on the Jane Street website all
your questions will be answered there
and I've also put a link in the video
description
our thanks to Jane Street for their
support
[Music]
you can represent eight digits eight
bits with just like two two digits but
I'm just
I'm just nowhere near as practiced in
that so it would be so much more
difficult for me to remember things